Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Bedirhan Cinar
So how many of you have a robot at home?
OK, I see about 20, 30 hands.
That's actually pretty good.
How many of you would want
your own personal robot at home?
I know I would!
OK, so why doesn't this exist?
Why can't I go to the convenience store
or the department store and, you know,
go up to the cashier and say,
"Yeah, I want my personal robot"?
Well, I'm going to talk to you
about how to make that happen.
The thing that we need to do
is to make robots smarter.
Now, no one will argue
that we don't have robots.
We have rovers that are going to Mars
and are getting science data
and expanding our
understanding of the world.
We have manufacturing robots
that are helping to build our cars
that we drive today.
We even have robots
that are helping our military,
that are out disposing of bombs
so our soldiers can come home safely.
So we have all this,
so why don't we have the personal robot?
Why don't I have my robot chef?
Because I can't cook.
(Laughter)
So, here's one of my robots,
this is a simple walking robot,
but it is by no means smart.
And so, what we need to do is
we need to change the definition
of what a robot is.
How do we do that? Well, the first step,
before we even start designing
and getting our hands dirty,
we have to come up with rules,
kind of the laws, rules of conduct.
And why is this?
Because if these robots are smart,
they might be capable
of more than we want.
And so we have to come up with rules.
Thou, robot, shall not harm a human.
Thou shall obey me, and only me.
Thou shall always protect me
at all possible times.
So we have to lay the boundaries,
the rules of engagement,
before we actually start designing.
And then we have to come up with tools.
So I believe that the way
to make robots smarter
is to mimic people.
Now, our brains are complex,
there's a lot going on in there,
and so, it'd be hard
to try to open up the brain
and actually figure out
how to mimic humans.
The best way is to observe,
is to actually watch people do things,
and figure out what are they doing,
what are their thoughts,
what are their actions,
what are their emotions?
And so, part of making robots smarter
is actually trying to mimic humans,
mimic how we do things,
so maybe they can do it
a little bit better.
And so, some of the tools are varied.
And so, I'm classically trained
as an electrical engineer.
I never thought I'd have to understand
things like child psychology,
infant development.
So, understanding that the way
infants develop to children,
develop to adults,
and how they learn and interact
is actually important for robotics.
I didn't understand
that I'd actually have to watch
tapes of monkeys
interacting and communicating,
because they have
a whole social kind of mechanism
where they learn from each other,
and so that's really good
to make robots smarter.
And, of course, neuroscience,
I've always been fascinated
with neuroscience,
but I never understood
that I had to figure out
why do the neurons fire,
what about the environment
helps us to learn,
and all of those really contribute
to making robots a little bit smarter.
And so, some of the things that I do --
and this is just a little snapshot --
one of the things is mirroring.
So they say our ability
to look in a mirror and wave
and actually recognize
that the person on the other side is us,
that self-awareness,
is a sign of intelligence,
and that allows us
to then look at someone pitch a ball
and figure out,
"OK, I know how to pitch a ball,
I'm going to mirror their improvement."
And so I actually have a robot
where we are trying to design
a robot health coach.
And so, I have an exercise physiologist
showing the robot
how to do some exercises.
You know, we want to get strong.
And then, the other thing is learning.
So, learning is important.
We do this as children,
we do this even as adults,
we do this as elder.
And yet, one form of learning
is muscle memory.
So how many of you play an instrument?
OK, so when you start off, for example,
if you think about the violin,
you start off and your instructor
might actually come
and move your hand a little bit
or maybe move your bow a little bit up.
So they actually touch you
in order to give you muscle memory.
And that helps you understand
how to do things a little better.
And so we actually
have a learning methodology
where of course, we're not going
to take the motors and move the legs,
and so we have to Nunchuk
to give our robot muscle memory
in terms of how to do dance moves.
And then, lastly, is creativity.
So, you might ask,
"Robots? Creativity? I don't get this.
Why does the robot have to be creative?
What about creativity makes them smarter?"
Well, creativity and imagination,
those are the things
that allow us to create problems
when we don't know how to attack it.
They allow us to make
something out of nothing.
I mean, if you look at the apps
that at out there and the tablets,
and the iPads, and the iPhones,
and the Androids --
20 years ago they didn't exist.
So, how is it that we got from something
where there was nothing and expanded?
It was our imagination.
It was our creativity.
And these are the things
that allow us to figure out new things.
And so, I have a robot that is creative,
it plays piano, is a composer,
and if you listen, it plays
"Twinkle, Twinkle Little Star."
(Music)
So, all of this together,
the last thing is interaction.
So, you have a robot,
you want it to be your playmate,
your teacher, your instructor,
you want it to interact.
And isn't it so cute?
(Laughter)
So, interaction is key,
it is key to understanding
how to work in our world with us,
and so the interaction piece
is very important.
It deals with communication,
it deals with understanding,
it deals with gaze,
it deals with attention.
All of these things together
allow that interaction
and our robots to be smart.
And so these are just some of the tools
that we use in order
to make robots smarter.
So, I want to leave you with one thought.
So, I'm all for robots and smart robots.
I mean, that's what I do,
I'd be out of a job
if I didn't believe in that.
But yet, where does it end?
How far do we push it?
How far and how smart
should we make our smart robots?
Thank you.
(Applause)